Aku akan mengajari kamu tentang bola yang berputar kecuali itu bukan bola dan tidak berputar hari ini di Qiskit in the
classroom kita akan berbicara tentang properti kuantum yang disebut spin dengan melihat eksperimen yang pertama kali menemukan buktinya
selamat datang di Qiskit in the classroom dalam seri ini kita akan menggunakan Qiskit untuk menjelajahi beberapa konsep fundamental yang umumnya
dibahas dalam kursus terkait Quantum Computing setiap video juga akan disertai modul interaktif
yang ditautkan di deskripsi di bawah jadi pastikan kamu lihat itu hari ini kita membicarakan eksperimen Stern-Gerlach
tahun 1922 ini adalah salah satu yang paling terkenal dalam sejarah teori kuantum karena dengan sangat jelas mendemonstrasikan bagaimana spin
kuantum bekerja tapi itu bukan yang dimaksudkan Stern atau Gerlach untuk ditunjukkan eksperimen ini dirancang untuk menguji model kuantum baru
dari atom yang disebut model Bohr dinamai berdasarkan Niels Bohr yang mengusulkannya pada tahun 1913 dalam model tersebut elektron berputar di sekitar
nukleus dalam orbital diskrit dan mereka bisa bertransisi antara orbital tersebut dengan menyerap atau memancarkan
foton setiap orbital memiliki momentum sudut terkuantisasi yang merupakan kelipatan integer dari konstanta fundamental kecil
yang disebut H pada tahun 1910-an dan awal tahun 20-an mekanika kuantum masih sangat baru begitu baru
sehingga bahkan belum disebut mekanika kuantum jadi tidak semua orang yakin dengan model Bohr seorang fisikawan
bernama Otto Stern membencinya dia menyebut model itu omong kosong dan bahkan pergi sejauh mengancam akan keluar dari fisika kalau Bohr
terbukti benar Stern begitu bertekad membuktikan model itu salah sehingga dia menemukan cara cerdas untuk mengujinya dan
merekrut Walther Gerlach untuk membantunya merancang dan melakukan eksperimen ternyata dia tidak membuktikan Bohr salah dia malah
membuktikan dirinya sendiri salah eksperimen mereka sangat sederhana dan hasilnya begitu jelas sehingga hampir menyelesaikan
perdebatan mekanika kuantum berkuasa pada skala atom mereka tidak menyadarinya saat itu
tapi eksperimen Stern dan Gerlach juga menemukan bukti konklusif untuk spin intrinsik elektron yang merupakan
properti fundamental baru dari alam yang penting untuk menjelaskan magnetisme superkonduktivitas dan banyak
kimia hari ini aku akan memandu kamu melalui cara kerja eksperimen Stern-Gerlach apa yang secara klasik kita harapkan untuk dilihat
dari eksperimen dan apa yang akhirnya ditemukan Stern dan Gerlach kemudian aku akan menunjukkan bagaimana kamu bisa menjalankan eksperimen tipe Stern-Gerlach
sendiri dengan Qiskit dan komputer kuantum IBM ide dasar dari eksperimen Stern-Gerlach
adalah menemukan cara untuk menentukan apakah momentum sudut elektron dalam atom terkuantisasi seperti yang
diprediksi Bohr atau tidak seperti yang diharapkan Stern mereka menggunakan fakta bahwa momentum sudut elektron juga akan menyebabkan
adanya sedikit medan magnet di sekitar setiap atom jadi kamu bisa menganggap mereka sebagai magnet batang kecil
eksperimen itu terlihat seperti ini ada tungku penuh atom perak dan medan magnet dengan kutub utara dan selatan
di sini medan itu lebih kuat di dekat atas dan lebih lemah di dekat bawah sehingga menghasilkan gradien yang mengarah ke atas
akhirnya ada layar dalam eksperimen tungku memanaskan atom perak sampai mereka menguap dan kemudian
mereka terbang keluar dari tungku dengan orientasi magnet batang kecil setiap atom sepenuhnya acak kemudian atom-atom
melewati medan magnet atom-atom akan didorong ke atas atau ke bawah dengan gaya yang bergantung pada arah
kutub utara setiap atom relatif terhadap gradien medan ini kemudian atom-atom mengenai layar Stern dan Gerlach bisa melihat
di mana atom-atom mengenai layar untuk mempelajari tentang momentum sudut elektron Stern mengharapkan bahwa atom-atom
dalam eksperimen akan berperilaku seperti yang sudah aku gambarkan sampai sekarang seperti magnet batang kecil yang mematuhi
aturan fisika klasik secara klasik magnet atom kecil ini bisa diorientasikan dalam arah acak mana pun jadi
saat mereka melewati medan magnet mereka bisa mengalami berbagai gaya berbeda yang mendorong mereka ke atas atau ke bawah tergantung pada orientasi tersebut magnet
yang menunjuk ke arah yang sama dengan gradien akan mengalami gaya besar ke atas ke arah yang berlawanan ia akan
mengalami gaya besar ke bawah dan kalau itu berada di antara keduanya akan ada gaya yang lebih lemah kalau atom menunjuk
tegak lurus terhadap gradien maka ia tidak akan mengalami gaya dan hanya terus lurus karena rentang
gaya yang mungkin ini atom-atom seharusnya semuanya mengenai layar pada titik vertikal yang berbeda pola yang mereka buat
pada layar akan terlihat seperti ini tapi itu bukan yang dilihat Stern dan
Gerlach sebaliknya mereka melihat dua gumpalan atom yang sepenuhnya terpisah di layar tanpa atom di
bagian tengah mereka tidak memiliki teori yang benar saat itu untuk menjelaskan ini tapi kita sekarang tahu bahwa mereka melihat ini karena
setiap elektron memiliki sejumlah momentum sudut intrinsik dalam bentuk spin yang hanya bisa mengambil satu
dari dua nilai dalam gambaran magnet batang kita ini berarti hanya ada dua orientasi yang diizinkan dari magnet atom kita
menyebut dua orientasi ini spin up dan spin down sebuah qubit dalam komputer kuantum
menyerupai jenis sistem spin ini dan beberapa komputer kuantum sebenarnya menggunakan qubit yang dibuat dari state spin elektron
jadi kita bisa melakukan eksperimen Stern-Gerlach sendiri dengan Qiskit dan qubit dalam komputer kuantum IBM mari
petakan state spin up elektron sebagai state nol dari qubit dan state spin down sebagai state satu
pada qubit ketika partikel perak keluar dari tungku mereka memiliki momen magnetik yang diorientasikan secara acak kita
bisa memodelkan eksperimen Stern-Gerlach dengan membuat quantum circuit sederhana dengan qubit tunggal yang dimulai dalam state nol
ini disebut diagram circuit di mana kabel atas adalah qubit dan operasi yang diterapkan ke qubit
ditampilkan sebagai kotak pada kabel kotak RX dan RZ adalah quantum gate yang
secara efektif memutar orientasi magnetik atom kita bisa memilih nilai Theta dan F yang acak di sini untuk memutar
qubit secara acak ini meniru tungku yang memuntahkan atom dengan orientasi spin yang acak kotak abu-abu adalah
pengukuran kita yang memberi tahu kita apakah qubit dalam state nol atau satu dan mengirimkan pengukuran itu ke bit klasik
garis ganda berlabel C bagian ini setara dengan mengukur apakah atom dalam spin up atau spin down dengan melihat
titik mana yang digenainya di layar kita bisa menggunakan Qiskit primitive yang disebut sampler untuk menjalankan eksperimen berkali-kali masing-masing dengan
nilai acak yang berbeda untuk Theta dan f setelah 100 sampel kita mendapatkan histogram pengukuran yang terlihat seperti ini sekitar
50% dari waktu qubit diukur menjadi nol dan 50% dari waktu itu dalam state 1 ini adalah hasil yang sama yang dilihat Stern
dan Gerlach selalu spin up atau spin down tapi tidak pernah di antaranya pada titik ini kamu mungkin berpikir ya memang
tentu saja kita mendapat dua hasil diskrit kita melakukan eksperimen pada komputer kuantum digital yang selalu mengembalikan
WEBVTT
nol atau satu dan ini benar tapi ingat bahwa alasan keseluruhan komputer kuantum mengembalikan hasil biner sebenarnya
kenapa Quantum Computing bisa bekerja sama sekali adalah persis karena kuantisasi spin yang pertama kali ditemukan Stern dan Gerlach
qubit dalam komputer kuantum IBM tidak berbasis pada spin tapi banyak komputer kuantum lainnya menggunakan spin jadi melakukan
eksperimen Stern-Gerlach pada komputer kuantum memungkinkan kita untuk benar-benar menemukan kembali kuantisasi spin
sejak tahun 1922 banyak ekstensi tak terhitung dari eksperimen Stern-Gerlach asli telah dilakukan ekstensi-ekstensi ini melibatkan
pengiriman berkas atom yang sama melalui beberapa aparatus Stern-Gerlach untuk melihat bagaimana spin berperilaku dalam berbagai
skenario ini salah satunya mari kita kirim atom melalui satu aparatus untuk memisahkan berkas menjadi dua yang sesuai dengan
berkas spin up dan berkas spin down dan kemudian kirim masing-masing berkas tersebut melalui aparatus terpisah masing-masing
sendiri dengan Qiskit quantum circuit yang sesuai dengan eksperimen ini mirip dengan yang terakhir tapi dengan dua
pengukuran bukan satu di sini kita sudah mengganti rotasi acak yang meniru efek tungku dengan
gate yang disebut Hadamard karena menerapkan Hadamard akan memberi kita probabilitas pengukuran yang sama seperti yang dilakukan tungku
tapi jauh lebih sederhana untuk digunakan jadi kita mengukur sekali dan kemudian dua kali dan
histogram pengukuran yang dihasilkan dari eksperimen terlihat seperti ini di mana string bit pada sumbu X sesuai dengan
hasil dari dua pengukuran kalau qubit diukur nol kedua kali itu sesuai dengan string bit 0 0 atau kalau
diukur pertama nol lalu satu itu sesuai dengan nol satu dan seterusnya terlihat bahwa kalau diukur spin up dalam
eksperimen pertama itu akan spin up dalam eksperimen kedua sama dengan atom spin down yang berarti dalam eksperimen pertama
kita memiliki probabilitas yang sama untuk mengukur up atau down tapi pada eksperimen kedua hasilnya sudah ditentukan jadi
dua layar di akhir masing-masing dari aparatus Stern-Gerlach kedua masing-masing hanya akan memiliki satu titik satu layar akan memiliki
semua atom spin up dan satu layar akan memiliki semua atom spin down untuk eksperimen berikutnya mari
kita mulai dengan berkas atom spin up murni dengan eksperimen Stern-Gerlach fisik yang sebenarnya kamu bisa melakukan ini dengan mengirimkan
mereka melalui aparatus Stern-Gerlach dan memblokir berkas yang dibelokkan ke bawah jadi semua atom yang dibelokkan ke atas adalah
spin up sekarang mari kita kirimkan berkas ini melalui aparatus Stern-Gerlach lain tapi kali ini mari kita putar magnet 90° sehingga
gradien medan akan membelokkan atom yang bergerak ke arah ini ke kiri atau ke kanan sebaliknya apakah kita
akan melihat satu titik atau dua atau sesuatu yang benar-benar berbeda untuk eksperimen ini
kita akan menjalankan circuit berikut di Qiskit kita akan mulai dalam state nol karena berkas atom kita dalam eksperimen ini semuanya
spin up kemudian Hadamard gate ini menukar koordinat x dan z sehingga memiliki efek memutar
aparatus Stern-Gerlach jadi sekarang kita mengukur proyeksi spin ke kiri atau kanan daripada ke atas atau ke bawah di sini kita mendapatkan
histogram pengukuran yang terlihat seperti ini jadi kita bisa melihat bahwa spin sepanjang X juga hanya bisa mengambil dua nilai
yang bisa kita sebut spin kiri dan spin kanan jadi eksperimen ini menunjukkan bahwa kalau kamu mengukur proyeksi X dari spin
yang sebelumnya diukur menjadi spin up sepanjang Z itu akan spin kiri atau kanan dengan probabilitas yang sama mari kita kontraskan
ini terakhir kali dengan ekspektasi klasik hanya untuk benar-benar menyoroti perbedaannya secara klasik ingat bahwa aku
mengatakan bahwa kalau magnet batang atom kecil menunjuk tegak lurus terhadap gradien medan magnet dari aparatus
gaya pada atom tersebut harusnya nol tidak harus dibelokkan ke atas atau ke bawah dalam kasus itu kita hanya melihat satu titik di
tengah layar sebaliknya kita melihat dua titik jadi setengah atom memiliki spin kiri dan setengahnya spin kanan meskipun
sebelumnya diukur menjadi up jadi dari perspektif mekanika kuantum meskipun mungkin menggoda untuk
menyamakan spin up dengan vektor yang menunjuk ke atas dan spin down dengan vektor yang menunjuk ke bawah ini tidak sesederhana itu seperti yang bisa kita lihat
dari eksperimen terakhir untuk benar-benar memahami apa yang terjadi di sini kita perlu mendalami lebih lanjut topik
superposisi kuantum dan pengukuran yang akan menjadi video untuk hari lain sama seperti kita tersisa dengan lebih banyak
pertanyaan tentang bagaimana tepatnya mekanika kuantum bekerja begitu pula Stern dan Gerlach eksperimen mereka tidak menjelaskan
segalanya tapi ini membawa kemajuan besar dalam menetapkan mekanika kuantum sebagai hal yang penting untuk memahami dunia
alami ini adalah salah satu eksperimen dasar yang paling penting dalam mekanika kuantum yang baik membuktikan kuantisasi
momentum maupun memberikan bukti untuk properti fundamental baru dari alam yang disebut spin untuk benar-benar bergulat dengan dan
memahami aturan dunia kuantum fisikawan seperti Stern dan Gerlach harus mau kotor tangan mereka merancang
eksperimen membuat prediksi dan terkadang salah sungguh tidak ada pengganti untuk mencoba sendiri
jadi kalau kamu ingin mencoba menjalankan beberapa eksperimen kuantum nyata kunjungi modul Stern-Gerlach
yang ditautkan di deskripsi terima kasih sudah menonton dan sampai jumpa lain kali